thank you very much I'm Dan SD professor
here in the Yale Law School beautiful
auditorium that we're in as part of the
Yale Law School as well as a professor
in the environment school across the
campus and director of the Yale center
for environmental law and policy that's
been at the core of the organizational
effort for today's program and on a
welcome all of you to Yale and to our
governor's conference on climate change
I can't help as a professor but offer a
little lesson on federalism it is a
great joy to live in a country that has
multiple levels of government and where
there is policy failure at one level and
I think with regard to the issue of
climate change it's hard to argue that
there hasn't been some degree of failure
in Washington we have the great fortune
to have leadership at the state and
local level and we have with us today
not only two governors who have been at
the forefront of that charge but two
Canadian premiers as well who in their
own provinces have similarly pushed
forward the issue of a response to
climate change in a thoughtful in
serious way we are going to spend some
time this morning talking through the
issues of what states are doing and I
want to start by celebrating the
leadership of these states governor
Corzine has done a remarkable job in
advancing probably the toughest
greenhouse gas control program of any
state governor Sebelius has also done
remarkable things in pushing back on
players that have not taken seriously
the issue of controlling greenhouse gas
emissions we will layer today released a
declaration that adds additional
governors and additional States to the
call for action emanating from New Haven
here today that 18 states set of
governors represents more than half the
population in the United States more
than half the emissions of the United
States and to move these states forward
ensures that this country is on a track
towards a serious thoughtful and
significant response to the issue of
climate change indeed the state's
signing on to this declaration today
have emissions as significant and
substantive as Britain
France Italy and Germany so this is
equivalent to the biggest economies of
Europe stepping up today for an action
agenda our program today will be
moderated by Scott Pelley of 60 minutes
he's been with CBS News for 20 years
he's a former White House correspondent
and most importantly for today he's
covered climate changes an issue for
many years from the Arctic to the
Antarctic to the freezing temperatures
of Washington Scott Pelley
thank you Dan very much always such a
great pleasure to be here at Yale you
know when I have a captive audience in a
room like this it reminds me of a trip
that I took with my son who was ten
years old at the time out to Lake Placid
and I had arranged to get a canoe and I
got him up before dawn and we pushed the
canoe out onto the lake Lake was flat as
a mirror balloons were calling the mist
was rising it was every father's dream
as we paddled out on the lake completely
alone I heard the soft sound of my
little boy's voice and he said dad do we
have to do this so yes we do have to do
this but fortunately you're not alone
with me in the canoe today we have some
fascinating people to speak with
governor Kathleen Sebelius of Kansas
Democratic governor had just yesterday
she told me be towed again a bill in her
state that would permit the building of
two coal-fired power plants which she
believes
which she believes would add to co2
emissions in her state but as you might
imagine the business interests of her
state are not very pleased with that
governor jon corzine has signed new
jersey up to the to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions to 1990 levels by the year
twenty twenty among many proposals
governor Corzine has pushed for his
state of New Jersey premier Jean sharae
of Quebec has committed his province to
a green plan that would put it in line
with the Kyoto protocols and premier
Gary dewer premiere of Manitoba has been
named as Businessweek named by
Businessweek as one of the top 20
international leaders on climate change
issues in the world so we are very
pleased to have all of them with us
today for those of you in the audience
for those of you in the audience we're
going to have a little bit of time for a
question and answer session a little bit
later in the hour but first Yale has
asked me to give each of the governor's
in premiers five minutes five minutes is
something a television reporter
understands not always true for
politicians however we're going to try
to hold them to this number give each of
the governors and premieres five minutes
to speak to you about what's happening
in their states today particularly these
would be their cooperation or lack
thereof with the federal government and
I will start with governor Sebelius well
thank you very much Scott and it's a
great delight to be here in this
beautiful school beautiful campus we
take John and I the Premier's don't have
to run here in the United States so we
take full credit for the weather here
today
but it's it's hard in five minutes to
sort of tell you what's going on I think
we start with what's not going on at the
federal level and that's everything what
we desperately need is clear federal
policy and a set of rules that then can
allow our utility executives our
legislators our business community to
make smart and strategic decisions so
absent those rules states have really
stepped up and I was thinking about this
last night that you know states rights
in particularly last century were
regarded as the most regressive kind of
policies the federal government would
set a high bar on civil rights or safety
net issues or other things and states
rights was a way to drag that back to
try and claim the opportunity to have
the lower bar at the state I would
suggest that in this 21st century that
that has sort of been flipped that
really states are taking lead in lots
and lots of areas because there's very
little happening at the federal level
and that couldn't be clearer than in the
energy area I've been governor since
2002 re-elected in 2006 and we came to
this debate late Kansas is a cheap coal
state we have low cost electricity we
have plenty of it so everything from
conservation and efficiency efforts to
any real effort to ramp up alternative
energy has been slow we haven't dealt
with a lot of the price issues or
commodity issues that other states have
dealt with this issue of coal-fired
power came to us through a permit that
initially was issued at the beginning of
my administration a continuation for one
coal-fired plant in the southwest part
of the state and we really continued a
permit that had
granted in the previous administration
that was withdrawn and back at the table
came three seven hundred megawatt coal
fire plants not prepare for Kansas but
to sell to other states and so that's
the process we've been engaged in in the
last year and a half one of those plants
was withdrawn in the middle of the
process I'd be remiss to not point out
my Secretary of Health and Environment
rod brem be who's here in the front row
who is the first secretary in the
country to deny a plant application
based on carbon and he really deserves
your attention so we've engaged a battle
in Kansas looking at the fact that we
already about seventy six percent of our
power comes from coal right now we have
the tenth highest per capita carbon
footprint in the country and so to
produce 11 million new tons of carbon
for power actually that we don't need in
the state seemed to me to be not a good
trade-off for our taxpayers for our
ratepayers for the environment and for
the future of the state the legislature
disagrees so they have passed some bills
stripping the secretary of his power
forcing him to reconsider the permits
not considering carbon and actually
tying Kansas to a non-existent federal
policy saying we could not make any
rules or regulations about the
environment in Kansas until the feds had
moved and until the legislature granted
approval so I've now vetoed the second
of those bills we've so far sustained
that veto but i would say that we are in
the midst of trying to make policy in
kansas about carbon capture particularly
after the Supreme Court ruling groups of
governors have gotten together John as
part of the northeast regional
association and he can talk about those
governors who really came to the table
first the western governors were second
as a group of governors coming together
saying we need absent federal rules we
need some standards we need some
operating guidelines and recently the
mid western governors which we're a part
of have made the same kind
commitment 36 states are in the process
of doing our own climate strategy plans
looking at greenhouse gas emissions
making strategic plans for the future
and 39 states are part of the climate
registry where we are measuring the
carbon that currently is in the air the
greenhouse gas getting ready for a set
of federal rules so we're we're really
trying to take action at the state level
but what we desperately need is clear
national policy we know it's coming we
just don't know what the rules are so in
the short term we're trying to make
rules that actually position us for the
future four minutes and 54 seconds for
governor spells Thank You governor
governor jon corzine of New Jersey Scott
I can make this quick get up let me let
me say it's great to be at Yale it's
about as close as I get to the admission
or through the admissions process I
really do commend the University for
taking the legacy of the theater
Roosevelt and efforts at at getting the
state's together to drive a national
agenda as governor Sebelius talked about
we have a vacuum in Washington with
regard to leadership on this issue and
that vacuum not only hurts the states
but it actually hurts our reputation
internationally because we are not
carrying what we should be doing with
regard to leadership and from the
bottoms up a lot of things are happening
as you heard in Kansas and are also
happening in New Jersey and across the
country very proud of what the regional
governors ten states are doing in the
Northeast we've been trying to work with
our friends and Quebec to have clean
energy as imports as opposed
a coal-fired energy coming from other
parts of the United States that then in
turn drift suit and other things over
our state's when the wind blows from the
west to the east we are committed to the
Regional Greenhouse Gas Initiative or
from my perspective the cap and trade
initiatives which we'd love to see
globally we'd love to see nationally we
are actually unfortunately narrowed to
regional efforts on it not necessarily
fully coordinated actually put a price
on carbon emissions create the the
ability to invest in clean energy
technology in the application of energy
efficiency which needs to be applied
generally we're at work on that in New
Jersey but I think once we get the
implementation of our cap and trade
program will be able to more fully roll
that out yesterday I didn't get to veto
but we did announce an energy master
plan that is very detailed in how we get
to those stringent mandatory objectives
that we've set our cells for 2020 and
2050 and I think frankly that's the
essence of what has to be accomplished
if you don't set down mandatory bliged
requirements I don't think we're going
to get there and if you don't create
revenue flows that allow us to invest in
the technology from the basic science
right through to the applications i
think that's not going to happen and cap
and trade program provides all of that
as well as transitionary money and i i'm
very proud of what we're doing we've got
a lot of work to do to take it further
and this has to be done and this is
where the partnership if doing the
federal government in a and the state
has to work together so much of the
implementation actually it's not even
the state's you got to take it even
lower into the mayor's we have 80
mayor's signed on to
global climate change initiatives out of
the conference of mayors because it's
its land use policy it's you know it's
how building codes get applied if we're
actually going to implement and roll out
the effectiveness of it we're at work on
this in New Jersey and I'm proud of it
we had the first clean energy program or
promoting solar right down to the local
community we've put on taxation
adjustments to energy bills to help pay
for this there is not going to be the
changes we need unless there are issues
that are applied on something other than
a voluntary basis which we once again
heard this week in Washington unless we
actually deal with the capacity to set
those rules and then have the financing
to make sure that transition so we're
hard at work on it I'm proud of it my
dep commissioner Lisa Jackson is here
who's really been the driving force
states are the laboratories but they are
the laboratories that ought to be
rolling these processes out into broad
forums that actually will protect our
earth as we go forward so we're proud to
work on it Thank you Thank You governor
premier sharae of Quebec thank you Scott
and governor Sebelius and Corzine and
Gary I want to thank Yale for the
invitation today and and Dan st in
particular I got to know Dan and my
other life i was in federal politics at
one point in fact Minister of the
Environment and Dan was working with
Bill Riley when we were negotiating
NAFTA between our governments and doing
a side agreement on the environment and
so I I remember him well and I want to
also say it's a great opportunity and
privilege for me to share this stage
with Gary dewer Gary and I worked
together a lot on this issue and he is
recognized as being certainly I think
one of the world's best leaders on this
issue and certainly is recognized as
such an in Canada it is very significant
that there are two Canadians premiers
sitting next to two American governors
today canada and united states have a
very important relationship we are very
very good friends obviously there were
each other's most important trading
partner and well beyond that here is an
issue that transcends our borders and
our national sovereignty and that has
always been the case but not always
recognized and and the fact that we're
governors and premiers speaks to the
very core of the relationship of where
action and will happen and has been
happening over the last few years let me
take a moment to say why this is an
important issue for Quebec the province
I represent you know if you close your
eyes and think of the map of North
America we are the massive chunk of land
at the north of of you and by the way
while I sit you'd be surprised I say
this also governor Sebelius because
you've just declared that you are
responsible for the weather we've had
the snowiest winter in Quebec in the
last I think 40 years so stop it
we receive enough from the United States
and snows enough at the point the point
is I want to make is why why are we and
this is a question that you know people
ask themselves or a country of 33
million people were seven point seven
million people in Quebec and a small
percentage of the world's economy why is
why would we be doing a number of things
that others are not doing if it doesn't
have a big impact on the overall scheme
of things there are there actually
people who who think that way well in
our case here's an issue that's going to
have a major impact on our lives in
Canada more rapidly and a bigger impact
than than average countries where a
northern country in my case in Quebec as
I look at the land mass that we have we
have an Arctic region and we are feeling
the effects of climate change now and as
a country and as a province if we are
going to get action on this issue if
we're going to entice others and
persuade them to act we have to
demonstrate leadership it's that simple
we're not going to be very convincing if
we're not acting in our own areas of
jurisdiction dan raised the fact that we
live both within a federal system of
government and that's very significant
and how actually things happen and we
both have national governments that are
aligned on this issue your national
government with ours and we both have
governors and states and provinces that
are not aligned with their national
governments and that's the case of
Quebec we have a disagreement a real
disagreement we support the Kyoto
Protocol we support the climate change
convention and my government has made a
commitment to reducing greenhouse gases
in respect to the Kyoto Protocol by six
percent at 9090 levels by 2012 and we
are going bye-bye the next 2012 and we
are going to meet that commitment we're
going to make it happen
I think is significant now about what is
happening is that we are seeing states
and provinces moving more aggressively
with more determination and commitment
on these issues than our national
governments are doing we are doing it
because there is a recognition now that
here is an issue that transcends our
national sovereignty that transcends
borders and I I think politically
there's something that's going to come
out of this that will be very
significant in the way governments
operate more and more we are going to
move towards a regional view on issues
that may go beyond the environment and
maybe they should but on this issue we
work very closely with the New England
governors with the eastern Canadian
premiers we've had a group that is met
for 33 years and the most significant
work that we have done together over
that period of time has been in the area
of the environment Scott is my time up
yet during well Canadian minutes or
longer than American meadows but by my
clock you've got about 30 seconds sir
but what we're going to go we're going
to go into all these issues as well so
Glee well go into these issues I just
want to reiterate then in closing
because since our money is worth less
for time worth more time is worth more
now awesome so we were delighted to take
it to our turn
and so we I just want to close by saying
it is very very significant in terms of
what we'll be doing in the future and we
both need to get our national
governments to move on this issue but I
think today if there's anything we
should recognize is the fact that the
real decisions actions are going to
happen at our level and so let's let's
make it happen thank
thank you premier sure a before we move
on to premier doer I understand that
governor rel is in the audience Jodi
Rell are you here on her way alright
well we'll recognize governor relevant
when she comes in governor I'm sorry
premier doer of Manitoba thank you thank
you very much Scott thank you again to
Yale for hosting us here this morning I
note that the governor's assessment of
the weather there is a slightly
different federal provincial
relationship in dealing with the weather
in Canada if the weather is miserable
and it very rarely is in January in
Canada its federal responsibility and if
it's a beautiful day like today we take
full credit as premieres in state
governors so that's a little bit of the
difference between Canada the United
States the Scot has been to Churchill
and it in today in USA Today it is
mentioned is one of the last places of
endangered places or species that you
should visit in the next period of time
because it will be impacted by and is
being impacted by climate change and
that's why we work very aggressively
with the premier show ray and Premier
Campbell as Canadian premiers on action
we work with the Western Governors the
Mid Western Governors the eastern
governors to lead act and be accountable
for action in our own jurisdictions that
we believe very strongly that the
shoreline risks here are also going to
be risks in terms of our lakes and our
rivers and our forests in Canada and
that's why when it's a very cold day in
January and a very tough sell on climate
change and global warming we have to be
out leading on plans and plans of action
I also believe that there is an economic
advantage for intelligent long-term
climate change policies low emission
buses that are manufactured in Manitoba
and Minnesota are the ones that are
going to be purchased in
California and in other states adopting
those tailpipe emission standards so
there's an economic advantage for having
a plan in terms of our plan we we
obviously believe in energy efficiency
is the number one way to proceed we have
had the equivalent of ten percent of our
electrical power reduced with energy
efficiency we believe in improving and
legislating building codes we believe in
a renewable energy strategy similar to
the eastern states and provinces to the
Midwestern states and provinces and to
the western states premiers have
acknowledged our twenty five thousand
megawatts of renewable energy in the
plan we adopted just a few months ago we
also believe in in having the forestry
protected and a part of a kyoto protocol
we have also accepted the Kyoto Protocol
and we are legislating the Kyoto six
percent below 1990 levels we've
introduced the legislation in our
legislature just last week we also agree
with the California tailpipe emission
standards and other transportation
standards that are very very important
in terms of the market and the
environment in North America we believe
that they are crucial and we support
them fully we are participating with
other provinces and other states on a
potential cap-and-trade system including
the accountability for those
cap-and-trade systems with similar
measurements between provinces and
states that I think can be very very
important for our future and finally we
believe large emitter is including coal
have got to be targeted as part of our
strategy we have eliminated one coal
plant in Manitoba we have one more left
with that will be phased out in 2010 we
have introduced a carbon tax on coal to
have revenues used to trans transfer
those industries to other alternative
fuels especially renewable energy fuels
and we we are aiming to be cold
in our province by the time 2012 comes
along now where we have the advantage of
hydroelectric power solar potential wind
power geothermal those are all renewable
energy sources to replace coal but we
are absolutely absolutely committed as
part of our Kyoto target to spend a
little more money on energy on the
elimination of coal plants it is more
expensive it is more expensive but we
believe in the long run for our planet
for our children and our grandchildren
it makes a lot of common sense thank you
very very much appreciate thank
thankyou premier doer when we do climate
change stories on 60 minutes we get more
mail on these than anything else we do
even presidential politics it is
astonishing we've set email records at
60 minutes with our climate change
stories it's always happened half half
the mail says gosh you guys are doing a
great job half the mail says you guys
are complete idiots you don't know what
you're talking about in fact senator
Inhofe of Oklahoma called me out on the
on this on the Senate floor not too long
ago and suggested to the fellow senators
that I was a windbag who knew nothing
about what I was talking about my wife
is from Oklahoma she could have told him
that years and years ago let me start
with a letter from the US Environmental
Protection Agency to Governor
Schwarzenegger this has to do with
California's tailpipe emission standards
which it has been trying to oppose
impose a number of states have signed on
to those emissions standards governor
corzine I believe your state is one of
them governor Sebelius has your state
signed on to the California not yet but
premier Dewar i believe and and also
premier sharae well this is the letter
that Governor Schwarzenegger received
from Steven Johnson the administrator of
the EPA when the EPA was informing him
that California would not be allowed to
go its own way on the tailpipe standards
and I will quote unlike pollutants
covered by other waivers greenhouse gas
emissions harm the environment in
California and elsewhere regardless of
where the emissions occur in other words
this challenge is not exclusive or
unique to California and differs in a
basic way from the previous local and
regional air pollution problems
addressed in prior waivers governor
corzine the federal government is saying
it's none of your business New Jersey
shouldn't be involved in this California
shouldn't be involved in this you have
to wait for Washington to lead the way
CN court
it's about Lisa correct me i think it's
about one-third of our carbon emissions
in new jersey and if we don't take this
issue on whether it is by what actually
gets purchased by consumers and there
may have to be a consumer education
program and the way the world is now
arranged until we can change public
policy in Washington then I I am NOT
hopeful if we would retain that kind of
policy with the next administration that
comes in which I certainly suspect will
not follow the same kind of logic that
you just expressed in that letter so I'm
actually hopeful that regardless of who
the individual is based on how people
have behaved and argued on the floor of
the Senate when I was there that we will
see that change occur and we'll start
seeing the kind of movement that needs
to be practiced and as long as we can
get public policy in Washington to get
aligned with what we see with Governor
Schwarzenegger what we see in the state
of New Jersey I think it's 16 or 17
other states and we've got a real I
think momentum to to address this issue
which is fundamental if you want to take
on climate change governor Sebelius I
think it goes back also in this
particular case it's it's the auto
transmission the tailpipe emission issue
but I don't think ever in my lifetime
I've seen the federal government set
ceilings and not floors typically the
policy is that the federal government
sets a floor and says you must do at
least this well and then states and
local regions try to exceed that try to
make a difference in this case and we've
seen it not only
in this policy but in others the federal
government says you may not exceed what
we have here and in this case they have
nothing so basically the EPA is making
the argument that you cannot do anything
because if you do you are somehow
impinging on our authority to do nothing
and declare that nothing will be our
policy it is very bizarre but the
argument is made and you have heard it
that you can't have 50 states going off
in 50 different directions or even five
different directions in an issue that is
so important to national policy it
creates what's called a patchwork
solution well I think that again I don't
want to speak for governor Corzine but
this is an area where Republicans and
Democrats east west north south when
governor's get together all of us are in
pretty universal agreement we need
national rules but they aren't there
we've waited seven years seven and a
half years for this administration to
engage in this issue and they're not
there so governors are not going to sit
and wait and let harm continue to happen
i heard the Premier's talk about their
willingness to step up and say we have
to engage in this effort we have mayor's
across this country of governors across
this country who are saying the same
thing so we'd love a set of national
rules but absent that I think States
will continue to move will continue to
lead mayors will continue to lead and
hopefully we'll have a new
administration who will see this as one
of the key challenges facing our country
and our world and get to work premier
charade let me help me with the politics
here for just a moment in a in a system
of provinces of the federal government
not wholly unlike our own what is the
political strategy here that you get
enough provinces enough major cities
together that the federal government
finally has to move is that is that the
idea well in certain cases yes in this
case in the automotive industry it's an
interesting area to look into as
governments and countries because it's
an integrated market north american
market so clearly here is an opportunity
for us to back together everything that
happens mostly in the industry happens
in lockstep well then what do we do
strategically to move this along well
there's a very practical issue here
there's going to be a change of
government than the United States and
less than a year from now and we all
anticipate that the change of government
no matter who it will be among the three
leading contestants now are going to
move on these issues and so my view is
that the more states and premiers and
move on this issue and state their
ground the more we will set the table
for the right decision to be made when
that new government will be elected I
think it's very significant at this time
that we speak to this now we did it back
home because we produce a lot of Hydra
where the fourth biggest producer in the
world and it's clean renewable energy
and and some of it as John mentioned
we'd like to sell the United States
because it makes sense for you and for
us but also because transports the
biggest sector biggest producer of
greenhouse gases in my jurisdiction and
so this is an area where it makes a lot
of sense for us to move and we all know
that we can't move alone that's the key
here I mean Quebec alone is not going to
implement a California tailpipe emission
standard it's not that's not going to
happen for obvious reasons but if New
Jersey and Manitoba and a great chunk of
states and premiers move together then
it will happen well that brings up an
interesting point which helps I'll take
up with premier doer the states that
would like to sign on like New Jersey to
the California tailpipe standards or
enjoying from doing so now because of
the federal ban your province also would
like to sign on to those standards
you're not bound by the US courts or the
US federal government why don't you just
go ahead it's a very good question we
support the California tailpipe emission
standard we signed on to it very early
on we represent a small portion of the
population in North America California
buys more cars rightly or wrongly than
any than all of Canada put together
so this too there's an the reality is
that if we have enough space in enough
cities and enough provinces joining on
to the California tailpipe emission
standards the car manufacturers will
have to move in a much more how agile
way to ensure that the products are
there that meet the California tailpipe
standards at the time prescribed in the
law so this will allow consumers to have
choices I would argue that will allow
our manufacturing sectors in north
america on either side of the border to
be producing those new products and
that's why it's so important that
california's want to court decisions I
can't believe as the governor's
appointed out it's being stopped at the
quote the federal level an
administrative level it is crucial that
we move ahead with the tailpipe
standards and it's both a environmental
standard but it's also a market reality
that will make a huge difference in
North America I believe we have the
tipping point of provinces and states
with the California tailpipe emission
standard and I believe that the last
Domino is in Washington and I think that
that will be once that tipping point
once that it goes down with this will be
implemented in North America because
there's too many consumers that are
covered by all of us that will be buying
those cars in the future can I just take
a moment to recognize governor al jodi
rell thank you for joining us very much
governor
such a pleasure to have you with us
thank you very much governor Sebelius
the chief executive officer of the
sunflower electric power company says
you have done a terrible terrible thing
in vetoing these two power plants he
says it will unnecessarily raise
electric rates for Kansas families and
punish Kansas workers and industries
which raises an interesting point if the
state's go off as individuals imposing
new environmental regulations doesn't
that put Kansas in this case at a
competitive disadvantage with other
states piece of B Texas or Oklahoma for
example well there's no question that
state by state policy is not the best
way to make environmental policy and it
is difficult not just for States but I
think for our business leaders for our
utility companies absent a clear set of
rules to make thoughtful financial
decisions if you're going to put a
couple hundred million dollars down a
billion dollars into a nuclear plant a
coal plant gas plus wind energy you tell
me what the costs are going to be and I
can make that strategic decision absent
that set of rules it's a very difficult
gamble the reality of the plants and
Kansas again was that the power is not
for our state it was for export power
the jobs are short-term several thousand
probably during the phase of building a
hundred long-term jobs and we own the
carbon 11 million new tons of carbon now
to me that's a lose lose lose situation
for Kansas we're making at the
administration level and through our
diligence of our secretary I think a
careful thoughtful and wise policy
decision for our state that we think the
money gathered from the operating fee is
far outweighed by the impact to the
environment to the health of Kansans and
frankly to the financial risk
that it puts those rate payers in
sunflower is an electric cooperative
owned by 400,000 farmers and ranchers in
western Kansas they will have the
privilege of owning the carbon that goes
with those two plans and they don't need
the power so if you look 35 years down
the road to a carbon cap and trade
nationally to a price for carbon
nationally their rates don't go down
they go way up because they now own 11
million new tons of carbon a year I
think that's a very bad financial risk
for those folks and we've been accused
of regulatory uncertainty to me the
worst regulatory uncertainty is taking
the permitting process into the
legislature where the membership changes
every two years and you could be a
friend today and a foe tomorrow that
really causes uncertainty into the
future so with all due deference to mr.
Watkins we see the world through a
slightly different lens we're going to
take questions from the audience in just
a moment so those of you have questions
get those in mind we have microphones
that are going to come up to you and I
will direct all of that but before we
get there let me ask governor Corzine a
similar question the New England Council
a business organization says that you're
going to force up electric prices by
twenty three percent in your state
because of the Regional Greenhouse Gas
Initiative twenty-three percent by 2010
doesn't that put New Jersey at a
terrible disadvantage with the rest of
the country a couple of observations
first of all that is compared to what
are you going to actually have prices
rise independent of what that increase
would be just to stay in business as
usual without taking into consideration
the kinds of things that I
governor Sebelius properly pointed out I
think most of those arguments that I
hear whether it's from sunflower or
whatever the group is that you just
mentioned are short term analyses versus
long-term analysis and the the reality
is is that if we don't correct the
challenges that come or the threats that
come to our economy from global warming
will end up paying other prices and they
will be very substantial at different
points of time aside from what happens
in public policy I don't think that
makes any sense in New Jersey we have
127 miles of ocean shore line but we're
basically a peninsula state we don't
need floods on the Delaware and rising
tidal conditions on our Shore that's
going to end up costing us if we don't
deal with it the carbon costs us in our
health care costs it is it is a very
limited analysis and unfortunately it is
very hard and political debates get
people to think in a comprehensive whole
cloth method that take in both long-term
and short-term views and I think it's
it's not a good rate of return on
capital analysis that those people put
forward Thank You governor I wonder if
we have a question from the audience
from for our premiers or our governor's
there's a gentleman with his hand up
over here on the left yes sir let that
microphone get to you and if you would
give us your name please and any
affiliation if it's relevant my name is
Richard stell I'm president I'm from New
Canaan Connecticut and I'm president you
can an environmental group and also a
group called Grail trains ecology
cycling and I wanted to compliment the
panel on their articulate discussion on
climate change but my question is with
regard to the region with regard to
Steven Johnson's denial of California's
request
and the discussion about regionalization
would New Jersey Quebec and other
northeastern states consider creating a
Northeast Regional Rail Authority that
could act as a modal substitution or
monel switch where we could reduce co2
by having more efficient form
transportation that people travel by
premier Sharia perhaps so you'd like to
take that one up and we we have a form
as I mentioned earlier for 33 years now
there's been an annual meeting of the
north-eastern governors and states
there's six states five provinces that
meet Gary has the same thing on the
western side and a number of things have
come out of that by the way and in our
case for example we have been
instrumental in pushing or national
governments on a file that's very
similar to this one by the way on so2
emissions remember acid rain it was
number one one of the major issues
between Canada and United States in the
early 80s in fact interestingly enough
the story on acid rain in relation in
regards to canada-us relations is
following a similar line not exactly the
same similar line than the one on co2
emissions there are a lot of
similarities and the way this movie is
unfolding including a change of
government than the United States at one
point that allowed the Clean Air Act to
happen under the Bush administration the
father at that point so this grouping of
premiers and governors worked very
closely together on this issue and on
reduction of greenhouse gases we have a
commitment that we established in 2001
to reduce by ten percent our levels of
1994 2020 now that is beyond what we're
doing now we're still working on beyond
2012 but that is the commitment and one
of the things that we're looking at is
transport and the integration of
transport now we have a major issue
though its security and one of the major
concerns in
art store a relationship the United
States now is what we call back home
thus thickening of the border and it's a
related issue it's going to be one of
the major obstacles in regards to trade
between our countries and who knows
maybe in dealing with this issue also
but I without going into the detail what
we are working on now is integrated
transport systems to reduce greenhouse
gases recognizing that it's one of the
main sources of pollution from your door
I've been to Manitoba I've been to
Manitoba in February I would have
thought global warming would be a pretty
good deal for you you're right warming
it up a little bit in February the odd
day in February Scott would be it feels
very it I would not recommend we have a
public relations campaign on a global
warming in january-february Manitoba in
fact that's what exactly what our people
did so the wasn't exactly the most
politically intelligent way to go what
we have to do and we we have to work at
this every day is besides the economic
advantages which I think being ahead and
innovating in your with the private
sector the public sector gives you and
universities gives you a real economic
advantage because it's just a matter of
time when people are going to purchase
the innovations the other issue is in
all the studies we've had conducted
outside of us in our own province
indicates the shoreline will be impacted
by rising sea levels and there will be
more of a buoy evaporation and real
challenges on the hundred and ten
thousand lakes that we have in Manitoba
we actually drain twenty percent of the
water in North America actually doesn't
look like a weather map you would see on
TV it actually drains north into
Hudson's Bay beside those polar bears
that you've also covered in your in your
news coverage so we we have got to make
the case that the quality of life that
canoe ride that you take that with your
son the the beautiful lakes and forests
that we have as a privilege to to
steward has got to be protected and we
to look at it over the longer haul
Canadians have now I believe
overwhelmingly supported the leadership
of Joshua Rey and Quebec and I think
Manitoban British Columbia have moved
very aggressively miss this regard on
the connection between Lakes forests
Canada and it's particularly important
because the Arctic the polar bears are
coming off the ice three weeks earlier
than they did five or six years ago and
we actually have a polar bear jail in
northern Manitoba so that we in the old
days they used to shoot the Bears now we
can serve them and we've actually had to
put at air conditioning unit into a
polar bear jail in Churchill which is
both humorous but frightening when you
think about what's happening to our
planet so we see it we're on the
doorstep of the Arctic we see it very
directly and that's why the tough sell
in january-february has got to be made
by all of us and I think that people get
it I'm going to take another question
from the audience I have four members of
my profession the Fourth Estate who also
have questions and we're going to get to
them as well maybe something on this
side yes sir and the red shirt let us
run this microphone up to you and please
if you'd give us your name sir I good
morning Chris Larson with the yale
school of management as much as the
efforts in your respective states and
provinces are commendable there are
other states and provinces that are
taking an opposite tack one of the
largest disasters in on the planet in my
opinion is the oil mining oil drilling
in the tar sands of Alberta which is
going to have a very huge impact in
terms of greenhouse gas emissions I'm
wondering if you could comment on how
the state and province driven approach
is is somewhat limited in addressing
some of those types of issues yes
governor to premier door i'll bug report
well i'm not the premier of alberta but
i'll try to deal with the directness of
your question on the positive side there
is now recognition that the oil that's
very very very much part of the north
american market for reliability and
affordability in in north america for
carbon
products is is a very good economic
reality in North America but it is now
being recognized for some of the
environmental issues surrounding it
number one water and number 2 emissions
the province of Alberta just last year
for the first time acknowledged the
challenge and put out a first step plan
the national government has acknowledged
it I i would say acknowledging it is the
first step in Saskatchewan there have
been there has been work with emissions
from carbon in North Dakota that is
piped to oil extractions in southern
south eastern South Eastern Saskatchewan
and carbon sequestering that's going on
which the federal government is now
funding as part of the solution for
those Alberta oil sands but I'm not here
to say we have peace in our time on the
very legitimate challenges on the
environmental challenges that represents
in in Canada I can't speak for the
premier of Alberta but I do want to
acknowledge that we've gone from
economic benefit to environmental
acknowledgement of the challenge it is a
huge challenge for Canada and for all of
us my pledge this morning is to keep the
trains running on time one of the
principal qualifications for moderator
is one who owns a wristwatch so I will
keep us moving forward Associated Press
John christoffersen where are you John
thank you John Christopherson with The
Associated Press given your ambitious
goals can anyone on the panel talk about
how you can achieve this without causing
too much economic harm you know in terms
of cuts and productivity jobs I know to
some extent everyone's talked about that
if you could talk about that a little
more how you can really minimize that
Governor Corzine perhaps you'd like to
start I think it's an economic
opportunity not an economic burden
taking on these transitions from where
we are today and where we must be to
meet those mandatory goals is exactly
what I think our economy needs and it
will drive all kinds of even unpause
ative unintended expectations with
regard to what happens in you know when
we develop the technology for more
efficient solar paneling when we develop
the technology for better wind farm or
offshore wind farms that protect the
environment when we learn to reprocess
fuels or sequestration which is one of
the answers to the previous questioners
view I think we're growing our economy
and growing jobs and they are here in
our own communities its enormous and I I
don't think this is a economic burden I
look at as an economic opportunity what
John has just said in terms of the
opportunities and I also think that one
of the things that hasn't happened over
the last number of years is any real
investment in the strategies that can
accelerate the use of alternative
technologies and get us to clean coal if
and when it exists figure out ways that
we can continue to prosper and grow
somebody said recently that in the last
administration in this current
administration about one and a half
billion dollars has been spent over the
last seven years in a variety of
technology strategies research to put
that in comparison Americans spent five
billion dollars on Halloween so it isn't
a significant resource commitment and
you can't outsource green jobs green
jobs are here and they're in this
country you can't put them elsewhere so
having a job commitment to rebuild our
infrastructure
extra green to move ahead on we're the
third windiest state in the country even
when the legislature is not in session
and you know we think there's terrific
potential and solar and hydro and wind
and power sources that we haven't begun
to tap into so I i would agree there's a
huge economic potential Thank You
governor actually we have a
representative from Halloween here in
the in the back of the room a Canadian
snowman I'm sure at this time of year uh
yes governor sure I uh I America roast I
want to reassure everyone we are not
canceling Halloween so we have I think
the question is at the very core of all
everything we're going to be dealing
with in the next a few years and it it
reminds me the question that's God asked
a few minutes ago about the cost of
doing things that always needs to be
followed by the other question we ask
ourselves which is the equally important
question is the Scott the cost of not
doing things and that's the question
that we
you need to systematically ask ourselves
what is that cost now in our case I
think there are a lot of great stories
to tell about the fact that if we deal
with this issue than right way we're
going to actually move it politically
from the column of what is in the
negatives for a lot of political leaders
now to the positives in this way by
dealing with the reduction of co2
emissions we're going to gain
efficiencies we're going to make
ourselves more productive we're going to
drive a more innovative economy and I
referred to this storyline of so2
emissions that is exactly the story on
so2 emissions and a relationship between
Canada in the United States when we
started on so2 emissions there was a
refusal on the American side to
recognize the problem and then recognize
the science and then we move the issue
along to the point where is finally
recognized to finally getting some
action done and then when that was done
there was an issue of allocation in
canada where the reduction should happen
whether that should happen in quebec in
manitoba we got that done in a federal
state of government that's always an
issue that's tough to deal with but then
the argument from the industry is that
would cost too much well in the end on
the reduction of so2 emissions the
producers gained inefficiencies actually
saved money are producing less so2
emissions this issue is the problem
isn't over with yet by the way but the
point is they actually came out winners
and it is going to be exactly the same
story on co2 emissions that I'm
completely convinced premier dork well I
want to make the same point the cost of
doing nothing is got to be factored in
and every part of any projects debate or
policy or plan and it is so lacking in
the public debate but it's much more
prevalent now secondly if you have a
plan and if those people who had a plan
for climate change and emissions five
years ago when oil was well below fifty
dollars a barrel they're making money
today with the new innovative
technologies on fuel consumption on
light innovative composite parts for
wait for transportation in our province
we actually believe our manufacturing
sector has made money even though when
we first came up with the
plan we were accused of being some kind
of tree hugger and with no relevant
economic model in place so I think
that's got to be part of the debate on
economics we have approximately 10-15
minutes I've got at least four more
questioners that I need to get through
who are on my official list of sir could
you give us your name please and your
affiliation I'm Ian balsam the Secretary
of Energy and Environmental Affairs for
the Commonwealth of Massachusetts I just
wanted to pick up on the question from
the AP and build on something governor
Corzine set just to say this that we
have a clunky way that we regulate
electricity in math in the United States
we can do two things that will drive
down emissions at a cost negative way
one is the way regulate utilities as we
encourage them to maximize greenhouse
gas emissions because their revenue is
tied to volumetric sales of power it's
an important point in our deregulated
power market they don't own power
generation they should be indifferent
how much power flows through their wires
so you can break that link it's called
rate decoupling it's an important point
that the states can do second is
allowing energy efficiency to compete
with power generation on a cost basis we
never done it in the United States and
you could squeeze out five or ten
percent of your electric sector
emissions quite easily in a cost- way so
the point there is there's no cost to
doing those things there's some
rearranging of our electricity sector
second point that everyone should
understand is that is the states that
manage the electricity sector through
the public utility commissions so we
think about a state federal partnership
it's very important that we look to the
states as the ones who are actually
going to do this work thank you thank
you very much
tot Todd Connor Fox News Todd where are
you there we are this is Todd Connor
ladies and gentlemen the Fox News is
probably best directed to the governor's
governors the declaration you'll sign
later today if you haven't already
basically says that you hope to shape
the first 100 days of the next
administration first how do you plan to
do that in which candidate most closely
aligns your way of thinking now and
secondly can you explain in your opinion
why only 18 of the 50 states have signed
off so far thank you well the good news
is that all three candidates left in the
presidential race are committed to
aggressive federal rules on climate
change so that this is an area where
there seems to be a very different
approach from the current administration
I think what governors are in the
process of doing is making our own plans
so that we know how to react
intelligently to what's coming and by
regional areas putting together targets
and goals which we hope to then present
to the new administration and say this
is what works this is what has been
agreed to in the Midwest and the Western
Governors in the Northeast governors and
we think this is the best framework for
national policy because you can move it
forward with a lot of support as to why
I don't know if the question is only 18
or I don't I can't really answer that I
know that they're more States than that
who have signed on to these regional
agreements my guess is that this will be
something that will continue to be
circulated and again I just want to
thank Yale and others for bringing us
together on this you know what a great
way to be almost celebrating Earth Day
and commemorating the the incredible
legacy of President Roosevelt to be here
on this campus and say we are committed
to the next hundred years where the
document that will sign
can have a huge impact on the next
century I'll only add that we ought to
underscore the fact that states will
have a role a very significant role when
you have the proper leadership at the
national level we've all said that in
one form or another starting with the
reversal the state's rights initiative
that Governor sabay has talked about in
her opening comments to the comments
that the gentleman from Massachusetts
raised to each of us we to implement
real practice of the steps that are
necessary to combat climate change
you've got to go local you've got to get
down to the basic elements of where
individuals use the transportation
system build their houses turn on the
electric appliances and that is all
going to have to come within a national
framework but we have to do is get that
partnership in agreement I think all of
us think that can happen in the first
hundred days whether it's 18 governor's
or it's all 50 of us I think that that's
the direction that the the country needs
to go and the globe does and we're going
to fight for it Sebastian Beauvais
radio-canada thank you I think the the
governor's just answered the question
but I'd like to hear the Premier's maybe
on that question what's the next step
climate changes do not know any
boundaries you have neighbors that may
not go as far as you're willing to go
what are what do you intend to do to
convince your neighbors that your
federal government and maybe
corporations to follow paths to go where
you want to go to tackle the climate
changes thank you sir bestie on the last
question it is this America this an
issue of American concern but in the
briefing the next administration will
get it would be I
it will be significant if in that
briefing when a president a new
president is elected he or she is told
there is X number of states going in
this direction and of course they may
ask what a charrette doing in Quebec but
I don't think that will happen but X
number of states are going in this
direction that I don't think we should
underestimate the impact that will have
because we after all we are elected you
are elected and you do speak for people
who gave you that voice and they will
they will read something into that
that's very significant now where do we
go from here you know in our case we've
brought in a carbon tax or among the
first to do that we're tailpipe
emissions California tailpipe emissions
we've legislated we are observers at
Reggie we're working with the New
England governors and we're doing that
we are committed to cap and trade I
think that's the next goal and
legislating caps that's where the
continent should be going we all know
that whatever happens in the end will be
significant if we are working together
as two countries that that's the only
real way that will get things done the
other thing we should keep in mind is
that on the issue of reduction of
greenhouse gases nothing significant in
the world is really going to happen
until the United States is really on
board as was the case for so2 emissions
you have the financial power to do
things the know-how the ability the
technology and so the election of the
next American president is going to be
the most significant moment in the in
the next little while in terms of what
happens we Gary and I are going to
continue to push on our national
government to go in the right direction
and work with our neighbors at the South
when you look at the three senators that
are now one of which is going to be the
president united states you have a
senator from Arizona I can't be partisan
I'm a Canadian by a senator from Arizona
that you've got Janet Napolitano there
is a great governor relating with great
programs in Arizona part of the western
team and governors on renewable energy
and cap and trade and other California
tailpipe emissions you have a governor
from Illinois who is part of the Mid
Western Governors group that signed on
with the Chicago climate change exchange
which we've sold carbon emissions to in
Chicago and you have of course a senator
from New York who was part of the group
in eastern United States and Canada so
we think this regional team will make
sure whoever is elected moves ahead with
us after the next u.s. election Madrid
my friend unfortunately we're down to
our last five minutes I have David
Funkhouser The Hartford Courant David
were you there you are let that
microphone come up to you David
Funkhouser with the Hartford Courant hi
Theodore Roosevelt the fourth sitting
down front i see gave an interesting
speech last night where he warned about
the sort of disconnect that might be
found between esteemed gatherings such
as this and people who are struggling
with their everyday lives and health
care and economic woes and inner city
problems and i'm wondering how do you
take people like that how do you speak
to people like that and what do you say
to them to convince them that this is
such an urgent issue for them governor
Sebelius we've had some of that dialogue
certainly in in our state about the
issue of these coal plant permits the
area where the plants were cited is in
the southwest corner of the state an
area that needs economic development
where a lot of the population has moved
further east where people are living in
a standard of life below some of their
Eastern neighbors so a lot of the
argument in favor of the plans was an
economic development argument and also
where power is more expensive than it is
in some of the eastern part of the state
and the money for the operating fund
would have helped to lower some rates at
least short-term what was interesting is
that it's also an area where people have
been stewards of the land for a long
time where they take that responsibility
very seriously where they've been there
and you know in hard times and have a
very close relationship with the land
and even in that part of the state the
majority of citizens think the denial of
the plant in the long term was the right
thing to do so they have put their own
short-term economic interests behind
what they see is a long-term goal of
preserving the planet and I think that
if people are faced with that immediate
it may take some education it may take
some conversation but most people want
their children and their grandchildren
to have a better life than they have and
I think understanding the health and
environmental costs of continuing on
this pathway it doesn't take folks a
long time to say we need you know we're
making a moral judgment we think this is
an important imperative for us to take
care of this land that we've been
allowed to be stewards up for a while
and at least that's what we found in in
our state takes a while for the
legislators to hear that same message
but i would say in lots of places the
citizens are ahead of their public
leaders governor corzine and gentlemen
let's take this opportunity for a brief
final thought governor I think that it's
clear this is another way to ask the
same question we talked about economic
trade-offs before I actually think
you're going to create jobs for a lot of
the people that might actually be hurt
by rising rates I think that government
has a responsibility and in Reggie we
are actually trying to use some of the
resources to be supportive of people who
are modest means with regard to the
transitionary costs and then I think
governor Sebelius talks about the long
run health implications of not dealing
with these issues it is an extraordinary
buildup of costs I'm going to do is look
at the asthma rates and I Lee
densely populated communities and I
think you can actually score pretty
quickly and speaking to those
individuals from your charade well much
much like Governor Corzine this is I
think if this isn't health care issue
and it is an issue about poverty and
lets you know just look at where it
affects us whether it is as more air
quality or the price of food what's
happening now with the driving cost of
some of the basic products I one of the
things that is happening now is that I
think we are finally realizing that this
is much broader an issue than we had
first thought some people thought as
it's strictly an environment issue and
it's much broader it speaks to a number
of things and I'm an optimist by the way
I think you know i I've seen the
montreal protocol on the depletion of
the ozone layer operate and it was an
innovation worked and it's not perfect
but it has had an impact on so2
emissions again I think the story line
reflects what will see on co2 emissions
I think we're going to come out of this
with some solutions but we do need both
of these countries to be actively
involved both Canada and United States
to happen in our federal governments to
be actively involved we are going to
continue to work together and in closing
one of the things I'm going to be
announcing today is that Quebec is going
to sign on to the Western a climate
initiative and we are going to be part
of that because we believe
we believe in all these initiatives and
we want carbon trading to happen at the
Montreal stock exchange and we're
working on that but we and I want to in
closing Scott thank again Yale for and
dynasty for offering us this opportunity
to share some thoughts with you and we
we hope that very soon that will see a
lot more action coming from our national
governments on this premier door well
that very good news about the Lebel
province given ooh the to the Western
climate exchange John has been a great
leader in Canada on all of the
initiatives on climate change and of
course as a former Environment Minister
he's got acknowledged that some of us
don't have as premiers there's a lot of
NGOs in the room I want to thank you for
all your great ideas we shamelessly
borrow I was going to use steel but we
shamelessly borrow any good idea we can
hear from other states from other
provinces from people in the private
sector and our NGOs and educational
sectors on how we can accomplish the
targets we've said I am an optimist as
well i believe all the work with states
and provinces and including some of the
mexican states i believe all the work
that's going on with cities in and
regional groups we've got we're laying
the groundwork for counting the same we
laying the work in terms of science
we're laying the basic plans for a
carbon trading system cap and trading
system I just believe with the
California tailpipe emission standards
with so many of us signing on that it
will not just be the environment but the
market that will help us drive this
agenda forward and I want to thank Yale
and Scott for hosting us this morning
thank you very much thank you
will you join me once again in thanking
our governors and our premiers for their
leadership today